hi this is presh talwalkar in this video
i'm going to describe how you can
calculate the day of the week for any
date until the year 2099.
i'll briefly mention the easiest way you
can do this on a computer is to use a
website like wolfram alpha you simply
type in the date and it will tell you
which day of the week you get
but in this video we're going to focus
on how you can mentally calculate the
day of the week when you're given a date
we're going to explain the doomsday rule
which was come up by the mathematician
john conway
so an example of how you can use the
doomsday rule is that january 1st this
year will be a thursday
when will christmas day be
when someone asks you the question
you'll instantly be able to answer that
it's friday
so let's explain how you can use this
rule
there are certain days in the year that
will fall on the same day and john
conway calls this the doomsday
so he noticed a pattern
that in every year
the dates 4 4 6 6 8 8 10 10 and 12 12
will always fall on the same day of the
week
and these were chosen because they're
easy to remember
it will also be the case that 5 9 7 11 9
5 and 11 7 will also fall on the same
day
you might remember this by saying i work
nine to five at the store seven eleven
the date march 14th will also be on the
same day as will the last day of
february the last day in february will
either be 2 28 or 2 29 in a leap year
and
the 3rd of january or the 4th of january
in a leap year will also be on the same
day so all of these dates will fall on
the same day in a calendar year
so how is this useful
well let's take a look at 2015.
the doomsday will be a saturday january
3rd will happen on a saturday
so we can find every other date in the
year relative to the doomsday
so let's see how this works so let's try
and figure out when will july 4th of
2015 be
the first step is we look for the
closest day in our list of memorable
dates so that will be july 11th which is
a saturday
so july 4th will be one week before that
we know that if it's one week before it
will also be the same day and therefore
july 4th will also be a saturday
let's do another example let's try and
figure out when christmas of 2015 will
be
the closest memorable date is 12 12
which we know falls on a saturday
the 25th is 13 days later which is one
week and six days later
mathematically if you're good at this
kind of stuff you can think about this
as using modular arithmetic you can
subtract the dates and reduce the
modulus seven
but basically since we know
25th is one week and six days later we
know that december 25th will be a friday
so one thing is this all depends on
knowing the doomsday for a year in 2015
we know it's on a saturday but how can
you figure it out for any year
i'm just going to show you some formulas
we covered this in the last video
there's actually a way you can figure
out the day that the new year falls on
based on this simple formula
and you can figure out the doomsday just
by adding a couple of days so if you
know which day the new year falls on you
can add two days to get january third or
in a leap year you can add three days to
get january 4th
so let's do an example let's try and
figure out when july 27th of 2007 was
that was the first post i put on the
mind your decisions blog
so the first step is to figure out the
day that the new year fell on
so we'll use our formula we do negative
1 plus 7 plus seven over four rounded up
which is two
this ends up being a monday
so now we know that the doomsday which
is january third happened to be on a
wednesday because that's two days later
the closest day to july 27th of our
memorable dates is 7 11.
july 27 happens two weeks and two days
after so we have an offset of two days
and therefore we can conclude july 27
2007 was a friday
so with a little bit of practice you'll
be able to use this doomsday rule to
figure out any date
from now until 2099 very easily
i hope you liked this video please
subscribe to my channel you can support
me on patreon catch me on my blog mind
your decisions on twitter at
preshtalwalker and you can get my books
listed on my website